my name is Vivian he banks and I'm  homeschooled from Signal Mountain  Tennessee i graduated in 2012 now I'm a  German and politics major at Hillsdale  College and a member of the doubt  journalism program this semester I'm  interning at town hall media as a part  of those days Washington Hillsdale  internship program the Washington  Hillsdale internship program we call a  whip for short we bring anywhere between  10 to 20 students a semester out to DC  they take two or three classes and they  in turn on the hill at the Heritage  Foundation really anywhere they want to  we find somebody coming out of college  who has some practical real-world  experience especially experience that  applies to what we do it really sets  them apart Washington is one of those  places that kids can learn a lot and  gain a lot just from being here for a  few months and that sense coming here  and having that internship experience i  can guarantee will be life-changing  you